the other thing is so here you are in a
film about a man with dolls and of
course you to your work have become
dolls there you are from the office oh
yeah what else we got we've got you from
anchorman I think you better without the
glasses there you are from act but that
is a really good dog kill the guy with a
trident and then me I keep in my own
pocket
[Applause]
not the only doll on the couch because
hello if they're one with your face some
other ones you know some other ones with
in the tactical vests and the camouflage
pants and the hair and all that stuff
and they have a little bobblehead
version of me which is pretty cool and
at door French if you be an action
figure
yeah I've done some animation films I've
voiced a few things but I don't i've
been mrs. beaver for instance there any
dolls no well we contacted friend of the
show Angela from quirky knits we first
met Angela I don't remember when she
knitted the entire cast of Poldark is he
busy answer but we luckily she wasn't
doing anything last night so let me
pretend
[Applause]
No cue Angela that's lovely
this is Eric - the type lady is a vicar
he's a priest Vicar of Dibley good old
Angela well Don her
[Music]